you know when we think about prison i
always hear would hear crazy stories
about riots going on in prison like when
like
were you ever part of any of the or
witness any of that stuff yeah all of
that comes along with you know you being
incarcerated you don't even got to go
look for it it's going to find you
you know
it'll definitely find you you know a lot
of the a lot of times so i started off
going to a level three prison
which
level twos and level ones are a little
bit lighter on
everything
level threes and level fours are a
little bit higher on you know respect
level just you know just different
things so
i while i was there in the level three
prison you know a lot of people would
say hey look if your points don't go up
you're gonna get sent to like a level
two or a level one which you're not
gonna like being the fact that you
already started in a higher prison where
the respect level is much higher where
you know there's a lot more going on so
when you say points just so we what do
you mean points so we there's a point
system while you're incarcerated it's
like if you do good your points drop so
you go to a different jail yeah they'll
send you to somewhere else and then like
a less
security like a lower security or
whatnot if your power if your points go
higher then you go to a higher security
or you stay where you are or you stay
where you're at depending on their their
um
like their way of monitoring your points
so my points were going to drop because
i hadn't gotten no you know write-ups no
i haven't gotten into trouble so
a lot of people were like you might want
to you know spike up your points get a
little write up for this get a little
write up for that
and then i had an older homie that came
up to me and told me straight up he said
don't go
jack up your points it's going to come
to you when you least expect it you
don't need to your points are going to
come don't even look for it so and they
did i started getting write-ups for
[ __ ] alcohol and i don't even drink
start getting riders for this that that
getting caught knives like just diff all
that stuff came on its own i didn't have
to go look for it so the idea of like
one like like not your mate yourself but
the idea of your peers of
getting your points higher to stay where
you're at is that based on just like hey
you're already here you're already
established you're comfortable you're
comfortable you know what i'm saying if
you go to a new prison you might need to
hit reset on you start over politicking
and networking everywhere you go like i
said it's a difference if it's a
different ball game and like i said they
want you somewhere where of course
anybody in general not just
me or any of my friends or anybody in
general would would love
respect more than someone that's being
disrespectful or you know what i'm
saying so in those places the higher
levels of prisons there's more respect